quizás se hayan dado cuenta de que
cuando están resfriados la nariz se
congestiona y cuando la nariz está
congestionada o se llena de cosas no
podemos percibir bien los sabores
imaginamos que quieren comer una fresa
se comen una fresa que normalmente sabe
muy bien se la ponen en la boca y
mientras la mastican se desprenden en
varios componentes celulares estos
componentes celulares liberan pequeñas
moléculas estas moléculas viajan por
atrás de la garganta y algunas de ellas
llegan a la nariz así que al masticar la
fresa también olemos las pequeñas
moléculas que liberan por lo que olemos
o usamos el sentido del olfato
junto con el sentido del gusto para
poder saborear la fresa si no podemos
oler qué es lo que sucede cuando estamos
agrupados y con la nariz congestionada
al comer solo contamos con el sentido
del gusto y al usar solamente el sentido
del gusto no podemos percibir bien los
sabores y las cosas no saben tan ricas
de hecho pueden comprobar esto la
próxima vez que coman algo tápense la
nariz y vean si lo que están comiendo
sabe distinto cuando no pueden oler nada
que esto les muestre por qué es
importante el sentido del olfato y
aunque definitivamente podríamos vivir
si en este sentido enriquece grandemente
nuestra vida cotidiana
el olor wooller se conoce como el olfato
por lo que a veces nos referimos a la
acción de oler como al sentido del
olfato ahora veamos rápidamente la
anatomía del sistema olfatorio aquí
dibujo el perfil de una persona aquí
está la nariz aquí está la boca y aquí
la barbilla aquí hay una fosa nasal la
cual es una apertura que permite que el
aire y otras moléculas de olor entren a
la nariz existe una región que no
podemos ver desde afuera pero que se
conoce como el epitelio olfatorio esta
región es el epitelio olfatorio
lo que separa al cerebro del epitelio
olfatorio es un hueso llamado lámina o
placa crib y forme este hueso se llama
lámina crib y forme y justo arriba de la
lámina crivi forme hay una pequeña
extensión del cerebro aquí hay una
extensión que viene del cerebro y que
está justo arriba de la lámina acrílica
forme que dibuje aquí en morado se
parece un poco a un bulbo y de hecho se
llama bulbo olfatorio el bulbo olfatorio
es básicamente un montón de nervios un
montón de nervios que de hecho es uno de
los nervios craneales que salen del
cerebro de manera que este montón de
nervios saca pequeñas proyecciones que
atraviesan la lámina creel y forme y
llegan al epitelio olfatorio por lo que
esta proyección nerviosa se ramifica
aquí hay varios miles de células que
envían pequeñas conexiones al epitelio
olfatorio pero sólo dibujo unas pocas
aquí pero hay miles de células enviando
conexiones al epitelio olfatorio y justo
al final de las conexiones de cada una
de estas pequeñas células hay receptores
receptor es sensible a un tipo
particular de molécula por ejemplo
imaginemos que tenemos un anillo de
benceno y la mayoría de las cosas que
tienen un anillo de benceno son
compuestos aromáticos y normalmente
podemos oler los compuestos aromáticos
si una molécula tiene un anillo de
benceno va a tener un tipo de esencia y
esa esencia es detectada en el bulbo
olfatorio por estas pequeñas extensiones
que llegan al epitelio olfatorio así que
tenemos un anillo de benceno en una
molécula aromática que va a entrar a la
nariz y se acopla con un pequeño
receptor en una de estas terminales
nerviosas lo que voy a hacer a
continuación es acercar esta región para
ver con más detalle el bulbo olfatorio y
poder analizar estas pequeñas neuronas
olfativas sensoriales y sus pequeñas
proyecciones que se acoplan con diversas
moléculas en el ambiente
lo que voy a hacer es dibujar un
acercamiento a la parte que señale hace
un momento vamos a ver el bulbo
olfatorio voy a etiquetarlo bulbo
olfatorio y como mencioné antes el bulbo
olfatorio está separado del pasaje nasal
por la lámina crib y forme esta lámina
crivi forme es un hueso que tiene muchos
huecos que permiten pasar a las
extensiones que envían las células
olfativas sensoriales hacia el bulbo
olfatorio imaginemos que aquí hay una
célula olfativa sensorial que envía una
pequeña proyección al bulbo olfatorio y
esta célula está ubicada adentro del
epitelio olfatorio también hay otros
tipos de células aquí por lo que las voy
a indicar así hay muchas células
epiteliales que secretan mucosas y otro
tipo de cosas estas células olfativas
sensoriales se encuentran entre estas
otras células epiteliales hay miles de
tipos diferentes de células epiteliales
y cada tipo de célula tiene un receptor
particular digamos que esta célula
olfativa sensorial en particular tiene
un pequeño receptor y este
es sensible al benceno entonces tenemos
una molécula de benceno que entro a la
nariz por las fosas nasales llega al
pasaje nasal y finalmente llegará a este
receptor y al acoplarse con este
receptor va a generar una serie de
eventos en cadena que harán que esta
célula se dispare
esta célula disparará un potencial de
acción y este potencial de acción va a
terminar aquí en el bulbo olfatorio
tenemos muchas células olfativas
sensoriales que son sensibles a la misma
molécula aquí estoy dibujando otra que
hará sinapsis en el mismo lugar y esta
célula también es sensible a la molécula
de benceno al llegar aquí esta molécula
de benceno dispara muchas células que
tienen receptores de benceno y todas las
células sensibles al benceno van a
disparar un potencial de acción a un
lugar particular del bulbo olfatorio
esta región particular se llama
glomérulo y podemos pensar en él
glomérulo como un punto de destino para
varias células olfativas sensoriales que
son sensibles a la misma molécula
podemos pensar en éste glomérulo como en
un glomérulo de benceno porque
las células que son sensibles al benceno
harán sinapsis aquí y lo que ocurre
realmente aquí es que hacen sinapsis con
otro tipo de célula así que hay otra
célula que se conoce como célula mitral
o en penacho y esta célula mitral se va
a proyectar hacia el cerebro la razón
por la que tenemos este tipo de
organización es porque es más sencillo
que una sola célula mande una proyección
al cerebro que tener miles de estas
células enviando miles de proyecciones
al cerebro y para ver esto con un poco
más de detalle también podemos agregar
otros tipos de células imaginemos que
esta célula azul es sensible a dos
anillos de benceno que están conectados
entre sí así que tenemos dos anillos de
benceno que están conectados y que se
acoplan con este receptor de la célula
olfativa sensorial azul
esta célula azul pasa por la lámina crib
y forme y asesina pge y en el bulbo
olfatorio pero hará sinapsis en un lugar
diferente en donde hacen sinapsis todas
las células azules sensibles a dos
anillos de benceno hacen sinapsis en un
glomérulo de dos anillos de benceno este
glomérulo tiene una
lula mineral diferente que envía una
proyección al cerebro así que esta es la
organización general de varias células
en el epitelio olfatorio la idea general
aquí es que tenemos miles de células
varias que son hipersensibles a una
molécula en particular y que esos miles
de células van a enviar todas sus
proyecciones hacia un solo glomérulo y
ese glomérulo tendrá varias células
mitral es un penacho que llegarán al
cerebro ahora vamos a ver con mayor
detalle esta parte de acá en donde una
molécula se acopla con un receptor y
como dispara un potencial de acción
imaginemos que tenemos esta molécula de
benceno que entra por el pasaje nasal y
rebotara hasta que encuentre un receptor
particular aquí tenemos este receptor
particular que está en la membrana de
una célula olfativa sensorial así que
esta molécula de benceno llega y se
acopla justo aquí cuando se acopla
ocasiona que este receptor conocido como
receptor acoplado a proteínas g
pg y se llaman así porque dentro tienen
una proteína que se llama proteína g a
la cual está acoplada cuando la molécula
de benceno se acopla hace que esto se
disocie y se separe la proteína g lo que
a su vez ocasiona una serie de eventos
en cadena dentro de la célula esto es
dentro de una de las células olfativas
sensoriales de las que hablamos antes y
uno de los efectos que tendrá esta
proteína g es que se va a acoplar con un
canal iónico y este canal iónico va a
permitir que los iones positivos que
están afuera de la célula puedan entrar
lo que hace que la célula se des
polariza y dispare un potencial de
acción que finalmente pasará a través de
la lámina crib y forme y hará sinapsis
con una célula mitral o en penacho
después esa célula mitral hará sinapsis
en el cerebro
hagamos un resumen de lo que hemos
hablado en este vídeo tenemos una
molécula aromática que en este ejemplo
es una molécula de anillo de benceno que
se acopla con un receptor acoplado a
proteínas rpg por lo que este rpg es un
receptor olfatorio particular
de este receptor acoplado a proteína g
se separan por lo que la proteína g
queda libre alejándose activando varias
cosas dentro de la célula y una de ellas
es que se activa un canal iónico que
hace que las células se des polaris y
dispare un potencial de acción este
potencial de acción pasa a través de la
lámina krill y forme hacia el glomérulo
y luego a la célula mitral o en penacho
que lo llevará finalmente al cerebro